elon musk
is the biggest troll right now in the
world that's true he's deciding
what happens to the crypto i mean look
what's been happening to those guys
one minute he sells okay no that's the
greatest thing we're gonna get
you know elon musk you know we're gonna
buy one and a half million billion
dollars of uh uh bitcoin
right then they make nearly uh half a
billion dollars
it was a trillion dollar you know it was
a billion dollars then they made a half
a billion dollars
and then he says we're selling we're no
longer accepting bitcoin then he says to
cnbc yesterday
he says to cnbc yesterday i never said
we sold we still have the bitcoin
and then bitcoin drops from whatever 64
out to 4243 dow
markets going crazy then it's
complementing doge saying i'm working
with the technology
but he was on snl the other day
basically trashing doge and
making fun of it single-handedly yeah
he's
influencing a trillion dollar
trillion dollar product he's influencing
think about the amount of influence he
has
think about the amount of influence this
guy has well did you see peter schiff's
whole take on this do you think peter
schiff's got a pretty good take on
on the financial system i think peter
schiff
doesn't give krypto enough credit
as he ought to and i think he's taking a
different position on it he does
bill maher does uh a lot of different
people do many
buffett and also our friend bill gates
not exactly what do all of them have in
common
they old as [ __ ] that's there you go not
not as [ __ ] because [ __ ] shift is not
that old no i didn't say
[ __ ] you said oldest [ __ ] they're all
this [ __ ] yeah that's what you said yeah
yeah so so the point is the point is
sometimes you're sitting there and
you're like oh my gosh what does this
kid know what he's talking about do you
realize i'm 72 years old
you realize what i've done in my life
and how many different investments we've
done but every once in a while
that kid could be the next you you
forgot you were 22
and you went up against somebody and you
ended up being right just like this kid
may be right against you
it just so happens that the tables have
turned out but the other thing too is
these guys the older people that have
that
opinion they like being rich they're not
opposed to making more money and maybe
embracing something new so maybe
they're on to something too but you
couldn't have two more diversion forces
between the people that don't like it
and the people that are behind it and
are loyal to it and staying with it and
the crypto scene
well tell me if you agree with this i'll
read the peter schiff quote that i
reference he says if a single elon musk
tweet
can have so much influence over the
price of bitcoin how can anyone
seriously consider it money
how can bitcoin be a safe haven asset
if a one-word tweet from elon puts it at
risk
it should be clear by now that buying
bitcoin is gambling not
investing first and i took the tweet and
i put a poll out
to the audience seventy percent agree 30
saying no chef's wrong that's okay fine
just like you say
audiences you say that right and this is
an audience that typically agrees with
bitcoin though but it's your audience
but
here here's the thing to be thinking
about what he just said right there
if if elon musk can go out there and say
something in bitcoin and it
changes the market the way it does it's
not the currency
it's the individual meaning if trump
went out there and said go download
rumble
and 50 million people download it oh my
gosh
rumble must be not real if a you know
bernie sanders goes up there and says
amazon is ripping people off you ought
to go protest and 200 000 people show up
to protest
oh my god amazon must be weak no it's
called an influential person
with a lot of influence at the level of
ilana i don't know what his number is
right now 48 million followers 45
million followers
elon can say anything he's going to get
attention it's very simple
a a college professor with three phds
and
four masters who's got 2200 followers
can go tweet something and nobody even
knows what he's talking including his
kids
are probably not following his tweets so
that's called have an influence so
if peter's upset about having influence
you got to give the guy influence
credit now what elon is doing that
concerns me
is um i
i i i just don't know if the market i've
brought this up many times
i just don't know if the market's gonna
allow a guy to have that kind of power
and that kind of influence long term
i don't see that you know he's there's a
double whammy with elon unlike most
people where he can do whatever he wants
on social media and he's got this huge
following and he just moves the market
unbelievable and then the media is just
as much of
fanboys as his followers everything he
does
immediately is brought out in every
single media platform
unlike a donald trump where yes he was
covered in the media but negatively 100
negatively almost all the time
so here's the thing he is a professional
troll elon so how much
validity can we put into what he's
saying because he might just be having
fun
because he's so rich effing with people
and knowing that he can wake up in the
morning do one tweet and have the whole
world react
this could be sport for him who knows
right that's why i don't put too much
stock in what elon musk is saying
about cryptocurrency yet so you when
he's tweet something you're not buying
that but
i'm not i'm not buying doge when he says
from the moon although doge i might jump
in on because mark cuban's behind it and
it's cheap
kai just put 10 grand in on doge kai did
you or he's being sarcastic
no he's a believer he is it is what it
is i just want to make sure he was awake
over there just you know
he's on the scene he's paying attention
he's paying attention to the dogecoin
to see how it's doing right now but so
so going back to this if you're watching
this if you're watching this i'm curious
who do you think
is the current modern day best troll
in the world who do you think it is i'm
actually curious because i'm looking at
some of this stuff people are saying
jake jake jake
musk all these different names who do
you think is the biggest troll we have
in the marketplace today anyways
here's a story of bitcoin since we're
already talking about elon musk page
four
bitcoin exposed stocks slide alongside
the cryptocurrencies elon musk once
again wrecks havoc
wreaks havoc with a tweet this is a cnbc
story companies exposed to bitcoin slid
on monday in the wake of cryptocurrency
plunging to its lowest level since
february after elon musk suggested tesla
might have sold
its holdings over the weekend bitcoin
tumbled to 42 000 on monday
several hours after musk replied indeed
to a twitter post saying bitcoiners are
going to
slap themselves next quarter when they
find out tesla dumped the rest of the
bitcoin holdings
indeed the price of cryptocurrency
climbed
somewhat when the billionaire clarified
that tesla still holds at stake
elon musk elon musk's mate 13 reversal
on allowing tesla to accept bitcoin
as the payment shockwaves musk's twitter
announcement says tesla has suspended
vehicles purchasing using bitcoin
just came three months after the company
invested billions in the crypto
except it's as a payment for its
electric cars but you know
again for me if he's sitting there doing
this this is manipulation
you can't do that you can tell your
opinion you can
you can say your opinion about what you
think doge is what you think
uh bitcoin is but to say
bitcoiner slapped themselves next
quarter when they found that tesla
dumped the rest of the bitcoin holdings
you say indeed what does that mean
you know i do feel like everybody is a
pawn underneath and it's a game i really
think it's a game to elon
i do he loved going on saturday night
live to tweet people for this
exact same do you think the government's
going to let him do that i think sec is
going to allow him to do that
i think they're going to crack down on
him eventually look at the numbers
bitcoin at 43k
down from a high of 65k in mid april
dogecoin 48 cents down from 75
cents even um coinbase right they
they've
plummeted since they're right they're
now below 30 i'm leery
of the people that are so outspoken and
so
adamant and passionate about it mark
cuban elon robert kiyosaki some of these
people
because they're very high profile how
much are they protecting their own brand
and doing it for to go credibility yeah
because they can't afford to look stupid
i have to tell you this
i have to tell you this here's the
challenge they're phrasing as well
you're ready
say you got 10 million dollars of gold
say you got 5 million dollars of gold so
you got a million dollars of gold so you
got 50 million dollars of gold
if you do are you really gonna pump up
bitcoin
against uh gold and your investments i
don't know about that
shift is a gold standard guy you know
kyosaki is a gold guy yeah
okay silver yeah silver and you even
buff it buffett's not a bitcoin guy
buffett's more you know
silver you know he's got a little bit of
you're investing so
so the point i'm trying to make to you
is there's a part of it also where
people are telling like for example i
own a zion williamson card probably the
best card he has
i own one of them there's five of them i
have one of them okay
this is probably a million dollar card
okay what do you think i'm rooting for
when i watch a
zion play you think i'm not sitting
there saying i hope the score
this guy scores 56 points goes to the
playoff does something i hate to make it
to the playoffs
tom injured all this stuff i'm telling
you publicly i am supporting
zion to have a killer career cause i'm
banking on it that's my motive
i feel zion could be a player so the
investors the people out there have to
know when somebody makes an opinion
about something go a little bit lower
and find out where they're invested in
and then find out when a guy gets up
there and says
this is the greatest time to buy real
estate who says that
a guy a real not a realtor exactly when
a guy says
don't worry stay in the market
it's going to be all right don't sell
stay
good times are coming who's saying that
exactly so you have to also sit there
when somebody gives you the feedback
you have to go to a platform where
there's differing opinions and see the
debate going on yeah but at the end of
the day people are typically going to
give you what they think is the
you know what their main capitals in so
anyways that's why
when you think shift and some of these
guys there's a there's a motive behind
it
one thing nothing negative it's just it
is how we are so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you